it has really caused a lot of havoc on
our charity
don ireland is having to stretch every
penny to keep her non-profit from going
under
i am a patient advocate don is the
founder of cdh
international a charity that works with
young patients born with a rare
diaphragm
and lung defect the coronavirus pandemic
has brought her work
to a near standstill it is going to be a
very long recovery
for our our community and our charity
if we can recover from this non-profits
across the country are struggling in the
pandemic
as the need for many of their services
like food banks
rise while donations plummet according
to the national council of nonprofits
an estimated 1.6 million non-profit jobs
had been lost since the pandemic began
and 13 percent of nonprofits have been
forced to suspend some or all of their
operations
national council of non-profits
president tim delaney
says the situation is dire we're often
referred to as the good people the
angels who are out there doing things
well i'm here to tell you that angels
have to pay their rent
angels have to pay their utilities
angels have to pay their employees
angels do have costs we appreciate you
so much
dawn who is herself a covet 19 survivor
has turned to online fundraising to keep
her charity alive
we're 25 years old and if we go under
there is no one who's going to do what
we do
she knows many young patients around the
world are counting on her
chris martinez cbs news los angeles